[Music]
i visited my mom in the hospital today
and uh and everyone there was asking me
if she was like mentally competent you
know because she had a stroke and she
just was aspirating or something and she
was kind of like so they're like we need
to know if she's conscious is she fine
she might have had another mini stroke
and i'm trying to ascertain you know how
she's doing um and i played my standup
special for her
give it up for my good friend and yours
wendy
[Applause]
there's a documentary i need you to
watch immediately why are you
complaining about this miracle in your
living room i'll turn this song off in
three
minutes
daddy daddy daddy daddy and i deserve to
see this v-neck and this dick that is
the move that's illegal in the nfl i
would like a big beaver magazine please
i've made 74 nickels for this shit we
put it on our face
should we just get in the van with that
guy i feel like that was good
can i have my ring please
she doesn't get it
[Music]
i know can you believe i'm not married
um
and 10 minutes in she went she looked at
me and she went
i get the gist
that's so mean and i was like guys she's
good 100
she's ready for just she's back she's
back she's back baby she's back had she
watched any more i would have been
worried
but she's back
hundred percent
mommy's home mommy mommy and then i
stepped out and cried just because it's
still an automatic thing i just do you
know what i mean it doesn't matter like
i even just like me when i wake up huh
what
what you when you wake up
[Laughter]
that's my brand but you can use it i
started cr i literally just stepped out
and you start crying i mean you guys
will
learn this i hope it doesn't happen to
you anytime soon but when you have a
family member that's like in and out of
hospital and stuff it's like it's just
this is normal what's happening to me
right now is normal you just have to
you know compartmentalize it sometimes
so you just deal with it she's fine you
walk out you sob for like four minutes
and you're fine she's in such good shape
she managed to break my heart at 8 15.
am so don't be patty and watch the whole
special you're screaming now and that's
like this how about this this is
actually even darker is that i stopped
it in 10 minutes but i was like oh i
don't want like in the netflix metrics
them to think someone's oh my goodness
this is so dark oh my god i didn't want
them to see like oh people are just
watching the first time
you're like no that's just my mom that's
just my family
so i kept it going with the sound off
like in the hospital just so it would go
to the end so netflix wouldn't think
that i like didn't have good retention
and that's when we knew you were okay
yeah oh yeah oh yeah
[Laughter]
oh fuck that's funny
anyway um you guys i put my hair in a
really tight ponytail and your face
looks great
i look incredible but i am starting to
lose consciousness
like i'm just forgetting what i like i
know more so than normal um so i'm
trying to name my next tour which is
just going to be like clubs so that i
can work out my new hour i love clubs
okay i love clubs it is actually as a
stand-up it is so much more fun because
it's so much more fun
when when promoter not promoters when
managers and agents are like you're not
a clump comic you're not a club you want
to be a stain it's like fuck off it's so
much when you're like a bread and butter
yeah yeah your life and bread like you
love stand up more than anything like
that is your love and people try to make
you love other things but like you love
stand up clubs are so much more fun yeah
i've done stand-up for 10 minutes
in 10 years and the most fun i had was
at a club
so i need to name my tour and i was
thinking about it because i wanted to be
very clear i'm in clubs
there is a business reason because it is
like everyone's always trying to
like get successful people like go down
a peg like she used to do theaters now
she's in clubs again maybe she can't
sell tickets like there's so it's like
you do have to really make it clear i am
doing clubs just to like work out new
material but it is also my favorite
thing to do joan rivers used to do clubs
like jonav because you make more money
in clubs but like the point is i need to
name it and it has to be a name where
you understand what i'm doing like
taylor's for her she said like the new
material tour are the
new ideas you should you should call it
i could be doing theaters sure yeah
trust me make that clear trust me i
always think about that that like um
you're welcome i'm here in clubs on
purpose like yeah
but i was thinking about calling it
because i am someone that i realize that
i'm coming to terms the fact that i am a
tryhard like i just am yeah i try hard
that's my thing i think it's cool
and because i was like after the special
came out this past week the feedback has
been wildly positive to a point that's
kind of like i don't know just for a
female comedian where you get destroyed
so much like
it's just been really lovely like the
most rough uh criticism i've gotten
which is very funny is that i did dress
like jay leno which is so true
very fair burn
um but
but you wore denim and denim and can i
touch it i know
why it's my second time but he didn't
wear the dark paint he doesn't yeah they
were like it was similar colored denim
yeah it's more denim tuxedo
yeah and so uh and so i was thinking
about it and then i was like god
everything's so nice to me then i went
on all these podcasts i did i did legion
of skanks live which is like the most
brutal in terms of like fans judging
comedians like you know what you're
walking into i i always get you and
eliza confused but then uh
so so that was
you're two very different people yeah i
always get um
brad williams confused thank you we're
both
right to your face
oh shit
oh fuck
[Applause]
i was scared just watching the clips
from it it's terrifying yeah yeah yeah
but it's like i come from the roast like
that's where i come from you know like
once you're not doing the roast anymore
and on like networking you kind of have
to like you can't talk like that as much
but i get excited when i get to do that
and then i did are you garbage what was
the supermarket growing up yeah where'd
you go safeway
okay
[Music]
man wow uh
tough they sell tires i did schultz i
did all these pockets that have like big
male demographics rogue and whatever and
the only negative stuff i've seen is
people being like why are you like
trying so hard or something all right
that was me and grace because i wanted
to
i'm rogan ho 44
i'm sorry
she should cut it back by like 20 hours
a week but i thought about it and i was
like is that even an insult no it's not
not people feeling bad about themselves
so they it's guilty
you work too hard but there is something
repellent about people that like trust
like they're well yeah i mean but
there's a difference between being like
a teacher's pet and being a tryhard
here's what it is it's that i remember
when anne hathaway
uh i wrote for that oscar so i remember
that all like happening yes and she got
so much negative feedback from just like
being a winner trying hard
franco dipped
he basically realized it wasn't going
well and then oscars with franco and
right
and and then she's broadway kid and
she's dancing she's doing whatever she
has to do right and i am that bitch and
then but she got destroyed yes there was
a whole article about it calling her
tryhard and i remember going like oh my
god that i get i get that's why that's
it's repellent to watch someone want
something really bad like it stresses
you out right just yeah and then i just
read an article about um how this next
generation is not doesn't fuck with that
shit they don't judge people for that
because anne hathaway got destroyed for
that right
there was just like a negativity around
her and then i meet grace higher grace
her instagram is
stan hathaway
and i'm like what's this ironic thing
like oh right like people didn't like
her because she tried too hard but you
like i get it yeah but it's not even
that it's like the next generation
thinks it's cool to try hard and be
talented oh yeah i remember when she won
her oscar for les mis and i remember in
her speech
she not that i haven't memorized um but
she she says like she's like it came
true and she's just talking about like
having been in the princess diaries and
having worked so hard and like finally
she has this recognition and i just
remember everybody was like what a gross
thing to say in your oscars speech that
like you worked hard and like you had a
dream and it came true like imagine
which is so
shitty and stupid
um because like
that feels like people like harboring
resentment for not being able to like
actually go and pursue their dreams yeah
but it's also what do you want the
person that just didn't work at all and
just whose dad was stumbling famous
right
right
do you want the person whose dad was a
producer yeah and gave her the job like
thanks got like what do you want you
know yeah yeah it's better news for you
that it's not just luck completely that
it's something in your control hard work
yes just be a psycho right and learn to
sing yeah right and grow perfect hits
yeah
so i had this epiphany this past weekend
where i was like oh my god the only
negative feedback i'm getting actually
isn't that negative i'm proud of that
and if you don't like me for it yes i'm
triggering something in you that's
making you have to look in the mirror or
something you know and uh and if like
i'm psyched to be where i am like you
would be too right we have the best job
ever yeah this is to me that you're
watching me geek out on my hobby als and
it also just happens to be my job so
it's like when people if i'm on flavor
with schultz or on
are you garbage or i like these people
like i like being around them so you're
also watching someone do their favorite
things right yeah i'm a little amped i'm
psyched to be there whatever and you
know
um might come off annoying but i was
thinking about naming the club tour the
try-hard tour because i'm like
people are like why are you going back
into clubs like i am because i want to
make this next hour great like that's
the kind of person i am i'm not gonna go
to a theater until i practice it in
clubs right you know what i'm saying
yeah i like that sense
clearly the try hard
tour
club tour
like try like work harder yeah you gotta
still how about still working hard work
pays off although i like hard work pays
off september 8th i am in cincinnati at
the taft theatre that's in a month i
will have all new material which is
wild september 9th i'll be in
philadelphia at the miller theater
september 10th richmond virginia at the
national september 24th charlottesville
virginia paramount theater why don't you
explain the background of
this new button
so i we shot we talked about this in a
previous episode and we had to cut it
out because look i know the good for
your podcasts are very short yeah and
they are just like you miss them yeah
you know what i mean
you just like if you blink like this
yeah
so uh something very embarrassing
happened to me uh a couple weeks ago and
we're just gonna play the clip
up i don't think i've ever in my life
accidentally like gotten evidence of the
weird stuff i do when i'm alone no oh no
i'm going to get uh uh plants for the
house whatever there's two locations of
this place they have pots and all sorts
of shit there's one in culver city
there's one in hollywood hollywood i
lived in for 15 years i now live kind of
in the suburbs and i was like oh do i
really want to go back into hollywood
like it's going to be such a rigmarole
like it's i'm gonna go to culver city
it's a little bit closer i don't really
know it it's like more of an adult area
and i'm like
right at the
like fork i love how you're making la
sound like a two like a one horse town i
feel like i went into town i got to the
fork in the road i didn't know whether
to take the writer it's like what are
you easy robert from living in the
biggest city in the country i'm on a
huge freeway
okay and i am like do i go right do i go
left and i'm on the uh phone calling
alex trying to get advice and it goes to
voicemail i was like hey should i go to
culver city location or should i go to
the hollywood location
and i'm like would you just text me back
and tell me and i just like put the
phone down because i was like right at
the
i had to make a decision right or left
and then i decided to go left and just
to go to the one that i knew in
hollywood and this is what the voicemail
picked up
hollywood
i fucking i'm in my element
oh my god alex i cannot believe
oh my god
oh my god i'm gonna die
i thought i had hung up and
i can you call me back and always
explain to you what that just was
well he's already used to that because
that's the that's probably how you sound
in your orgasm
[Applause]
he's like is she jacking off in the
car who's driving i was between the left
and the right as soon as i made the
right and i was like i'm committing now
baby tinseltown
what's your dream
they're gonna put me in the pictures oh
god like i do that all the time if i'm
getting off our backs
i like the wheel i
kind of am an announcer i just love from
the 80s i just love how you were asking
an urgent question on a voicemail you're
like left or right and it was happening
right then
like it's not like it's about getting an
answer is that not how you page a doctor
[Laughter]
i have a question what should i do right
this second call me back as soon as i
realized it was recording on a voicemail
in my head i was like okay
we are breaking up
and what am i gonna say i'm gonna be
like oh age difference like i'm just i'm
never gonna be out like it was just so
embarrassing and i remember coming home
that night and i walked in and i was
like hey he's like hollywood thank you
oh my god
so much
but it's good that you're getting ahead
of this because if he if it was secret
and he broke up with you he could
release it that's so true if he was like
okay my ex is crazy people like i i
cannot believe that people call the x
it's crazy now i'm in my element
hollywood baby so anytime i'm like
anything with any sort of hollywood
people because i people like it people
do like it which is why i don't know
when i'm going to use this button but
i'll try okay just to tell me to shut up
maybe i want baby
[Laughter]
um okay
this is a bad idea
um up today uh this has been the last 20
minutes or so have probably made you
dumber this next hour and a half will
make you much smarter one of the
smartest people i know dick costello he
is so brilliant i tried to really stay
focused on here um and i hope you guys
enjoy it
[Music]
we're on we just start this very
awkwardly no i love it you know what
first how do you know by the way in here
what's supposed to be here and what
what's garbage
there's one shoe
there's one shoe i'd like to point this
it's one it's one of one
that was um that's from the uh jeffrey
epstein museum
it's next to simply that is simply
sailing solution all right maybe i won't
touch anything else
um the answer uh is it's all trash okay
i love it have you ever seen labyrinth
remember
what no i don't know what you're talking
about i really don't i'm being serious
you didn't see the movie labyrinth no
but david bowie
no
ever
i don't i don't believe so you are
cancelled i don't want anyone to surely
should i get up and go it's homophobic
that was
i mean this is ant
this is anti-gay it's anti-woman it's
anti-goblin to not have seen the movie
how dare you
david bowie was a goblin king in a uh
movie called labyrinth jim henson he was
the puppet guy puppet guy he wore uh
very tight uh cream colored stirrup
pants with no panties
and uh dance with goblins all right and
um jennifer connolly
sounds fascinating we have no okay so i
we have homework for you all right
you're you're very much i very much i've
already got a to-do it's like two
seconds two minutes in i very much look
to you as like one of the smartest
people i know and now i'm now i'm
questioning everything
all unraveling so much for that if if
all these giant fortune 5
500 companies had known that you had a
dearth of labyrinth knowledge i can't
believe that guy ran a company wow
you've run a lot of companies several
not a lot it's a few let's go with like
a few what's your dream intro i always
do very weird intros
i know
the shortest one possible is my dream
entrance how about this the best white
guy i know
look perfect that's amazing the dream
intro for me is someone who pronounces
my last name correctly costello costello
correct which is by the way
why why
irish
interesting
how about that for a curveball how much
irish
uh half half what's the other half uh
italian so you have uh uh irish ancestry
italian ancestor that's a pretty
powerful combination good one i think
it's pretty good one it's a perfect
amount of trauma
a lot of hand waving a lot of
gesticulating yeah like insecure
warriors yeah a lot of good good that's
a good actually really good yeah yeah
it's exactly what it is insecure warrior
good that's what it is i love that
that's my that's actually my ideal intro
here he is insecure warrior
dick costello
um okay so
uh
i really try to stay away from talking
about politics per se but but
i would like to tell you how to vote
people love hearing celebrities and
comedians i didn't think that's
but i do believe i mean this is
a dream uh episode that's a dream to
have you here to be able to ask you
questions i feel like so many people
right now are just losing their minds
aging themselves uh uh thinning their uh
heart valves getting heart disease uh
fighting with
the
uh impact of twitter the supposed impact
uh google just you're the everything the
whole deal the king of all of this all
the social media stuff yes and i'm gonna
say a couple things that might be wildly
wrong okay so here's my
brand sure happy to be wrong
okay no ego involved but my gut when
when i look at twitter it's a it's it's
it's so it's so massive it's such a but
i think a lot of people
over um
sort of don't understand
that
a lot of it is like an echo chamber of
like self-righteous indignation and just
this circle jerk of like i think of it
as a mosh pit when you go to a concert
you can watch from the back you can
enjoy several different ways and or you
can go into the front and jump into this
area where everyone's just kind of
fighting and that's what you're signing
up for right and what i see and maybe
i'm seeing this through the lens of
addiction because that's like some
experience i have with you know growing
up in alcohol and having to learn about
addiction my brain and i'm probably
projecting it's just like oh these are
people that are addicted to drama
addicted to adrenaline because you can
unfollow these
people that are trolling you can opt out
of a lot of this drama and
twitter i think it's uh one of the
biggest struggles i think we have as
humans is knowing when uh something has
changed and being willing to evolve or
change with it so yes twitter started
with like just land in l.a here's my
avocado toast but now you go there to
fight
you know right that's what you're it's a
fight club people go there for news and
to argue with each other totally fair i
love it for news i love twitter i have a
great time on there because i don't i
only follow sort of news sites and i
don't get stuck in the weeds yeah
the challenges you mentioned it's like
going to a concert the challenge is it's
like going to a concert but everyone
gets to go on stage and be the dj for
two seconds
everyone's the lead singer yeah for two
seconds yeah great now it's my turn like
wait a minute no i came to see this
person over here yeah no no i'm gonna go
up there now for a while i think the the
most harmful thing i see
uh uh in terms of like impact besides
maybe someone who is the president or
i'm sorry
besides maybe someone who is running for
president getting more free press than
they should it gets unfair a little bit
because the biggest personalities are
gonna get the most free coverage sure
you know that's how i mean let's just
start with that do you believe that
political candidates should be able to
be on twitter
i mean but the thing you just mentioned
though that it's true is the people with
the most followers get more followers
because they've already got to these
followers so it feeds on itself people
who have a lot of followers get people
responding to them which gets more
engagement which earns them more
followers so you just have this like
feeding frenzy around the people who are
already popular get more popular do you
think that's going to make people start
to be like
unnecessarily controversial or
incendiary just to
follow that model yeah it already
happens you'll see people who are like
you get point you you're you're rewarded
too greatly you're rewarded to too great
an extra extent for punking somebody on
twitter the problem is that the replies
are just as
weighted just as heavily as the original
thought so you can write this very
thoughtful thing and then someone can
just punk you and don't wear dunk on you
and they get like you know it gets a
hundred thousand likes and then that
person's rewarded for it and then you
got a flight so you didn't even see it
yeah and then you land
actual thing that happens yeah like what
happened yes exactly yes you have to if
you're good yeah you have to be ready at
all times to be defending yourself why
does this thing have 7 000 responses
that's not that's probably not good in
your time running twitter and since um
what have you learned about human nature
that you didn't know before based on oh
man the insights um
people
uh the the things the things that are
amazing that were amazing to me running
twitter were
that people are so easily incensed about
something that seems
such an innocuous disagreement but
they'll they'll
they'll kill themselves in support of
something that's like an insane thing
they believe in right so you're thinking
like wait a minute you were like
arguing with me for hours about this
crazy thing you believe in that should
be you know we we should delete this
account you know it could be forget
about like us politics and let's talk
about like pakistani politics or turkish
politics or something that
people in the u.s don't have any emotion
about and there were there were turkish
politicians that were like i can't
believe you haven't deleted this account
you know we're going to arrest you when
you if you ever fly in this down bull
and land here which is a bummer because
i hadn't been there and i kind of wanted
to go the bombers are supposed to be
amazing
beautiful and i'm going to get arrested
and then you know
then something that's like this totally
like innocuous thing
they're like uh you know oh why would
anyone get up you know or or or
something that's like horrible they're
like why would anyone get upset about
that i don't know what you're talking
about but one person is a dog with a
bone and dying on a hill weird how
people will die on a hill for the
stupidest weirdest thing and then not
get upset about something that seems
totally crazy in the same country and to
me i guess maybe this is my point of
view what i come from and the lens
through which i look at it uh it is odd
to me that when we see the behavior of
people on twitter we assume everyone is
operating with the emotional tools we
are operating with we assume people are
all the same age education level yeah
they're not no i mean i see a lot of
people when i see that when someone's
like this person keeps you know uh
telling me to take that tweet down every
single day they harass me and i'm like
sounds like that person either has
borderline personality disorder or ocd
and is like not well like you know maybe
i'm too much like her people hurt people
thing but it's also there's no checking
for mental illness or addiction because
it's a very addictive platform i see a
lot of self-righteous indonesian addicts
who the same way you're addicted to porn
or addicted to you know cocaine or
alcohol when you say you you're
referring to one in general someone one
who is on twitter constantly
obsessively
following up who is like you need to
take that west virginia sign down
whitney in your podcast studio and they
can't stop i go
i don't think this is a choice this
person is making like do you think there
will ever be
a
20 years 50 years from now do you think
we'll ever look back and be like
remember when people could just be on
twitter as long as they wanted to all
day remember when people were just
anyone over at any age could have like
are there going to be any
sort of
like smoking or anything else that was
addictive at some point yeah this is
sharing i totally think that's going to
be a there's going to be a generational
generational backlash against the way
social media is consumed today in like
hours and hours and hours on youtube and
instagram and what and twit you know
pick your tick tock there's gonna
absolutely 100 be a generational
backlash against that like wow that was
crazy people were on remember when we
just looked at photos of our friends at
work for two hours
yeah of course they're like it seems
obvious that there will be a backlash
against that and these some kids will be
like my mom was just on tick tock all
day and you know forgot to feed the dog
and it died so yeah i'm never gonna do
that yes or just like you know when you
see these you know something that you
know broke my heart i've talked about it
before but about the girl who she was
hired to be the editor of teen vogue
african-american girl and she had
tweeted when she was you know 16 or 17
something that was you know of course of
course offensively held against her
eight years later she was fired i mean
like when you're a teenager i'm very
open about this on the show we've all
done dumb things when we're tiny that's
what being a teenager is you say crazy
stuff and then someone says you can't
say that and you learn in private now
we're all growing up in public and
learning in public right will there ever
be a day where we're like the same way
you can't drink until you're 21 or drive
without a license will there ever be a
day that it's like we're protecting kids
from like making really stupid mistakes
publicly on social media the next
generation will be like i'm not that's
crazy look what happened to my parents
i'm not going to do that it does seem
like they're self-censoring yes like
that they're kind of taking their own
freedoms away right as like an over
correction yeah
i i i think that's a hundred percent
gonna gonna continue to happen and more
of it because i i know um uh it was more
in surf uh a neuroscientist he was
telling me that like rehabs are now
opening for phone addiction of course
you know yeah of course
i was at a restaurant i mean we've all
seen this there's a restaurant the other
night and four people were out to dinner
and like they didn't talk i mean it's
like you see it all the time that all of
them were on instagram the whole time
it's like why do it's weird why did they
like
what they come to meet for
and then you look at a i mean i could be
a dinner with you and i'll be on your
instagram and you're right in front like
they're dm'ing each other it's like when
you see the fish parents at their kids
recitals and they're just filming at the
whole time
you know they're right here imagine how
good that
looks it happens all the time though
it's crazy but this obsession with
documenting this obsession with
recording it is about the way you never
go back and look at it anyway um did you
ever feel like there were
um
it's so naturally addictive but i
remember someone that was uh in the
initial team of facebook or something i
could definitely look up his name he was
very public about going like oh we would
try to make
this platform addictive oh yeah a
hundred percent they
are philip moore
they 100 that was that was 100 like the
more engagement you could get the better
that was
a thousand percent the facebook growth
team's
motivation i don't think they even i
don't think they would disagree with
that because their business models we
need to keep them on this platform as
long as possible
well they wanted like more engagement
means more engagement is better more is
better i think that was always i don't i
don't think they would ever have any
qualms about
about that that was always there but
they have like scientists that are going
like this how the brain works let's test
this let's test this versus this what
keeps them on what drives more
engagement more daily active usage and
more hours a day and
optimized for that and it's more more
likes more colors more rewards more
sounds yeah
yeah yeah and it's simple stuff like you
know
show the um number of likes changing as
it changes instead of like having to
refresh to see the number change and
that will keep people on more because
they'll want to see if the number of
likes goes up in real time while they're
staring at it all that stuff works i
mean works
in the sense that it keeps people on
more and keeps them
on your platform longer all those things
all those psychological tools they work
right it's it i think of them kind of
like as drug companies in a way you know
it's kind of like it's
it's there is
it but i also don't think it's
it's tricky i don't think it is a
private company's job
to decide
what is moral and who can and can't be
that's when it gets a little bit dicey
for me you get to start a business and
decide what your business is yeah you
know so as much as i disagree with the
guy who owned the cake store who
wouldn't make a cake for the gay couple
first of all why are you going to
straight guy to make her cake it's going
to look like shit so by the way you
dodged a bullet don't just don't go
there you're the gay couple made a
mistake yeah in that cake how did you
not know a better you know pastry person
um and uh they were newly gay they just
came out of the closet they were still
going to ralphs for their cakes or
something i don't know what's happening
but
as much as i disagree with that yeah you
know yeah yeah the best way to get that
person to go out of business or for
justice to be served i believe is to
boycott and then stop giving them your
business and then eventually they the
same thing with fur no one stopped
making fur because they ethically
believed it was it just stopped selling
yeah
people stopped buying it karl lagerfeld
was like but i love puppies like he you
know i mean no one
so
it's tricky because whenever people are
like this person should be kicked off
twitter for saying this this person
should be cooked up yeah yeah that
doesn't solve the problem in the real
world totally agree the other issue is
people will sometimes say to me well you
know what twitter should you do is just
like say you know we're just going to
use the first amendment and i always
would tell these people you realize that
the first amendment is just first of all
the first amendment is a united states
constitution rule that applies only to
you know
a public speech in the united states
twitter is used like all over the world
germany doesn't have the first amendment
in germany down slow down
back up back up
back up for a second
what there are other countries on this
globe
since when
okay the first amendment only applies to
americans yeah
right no but people would say just use
the first amendment to decide what you
can and can't put on twitter well
in turkey it's illegal to refer to
ataturk the founder of the country is
gay and people would do that all the
time on twitter and then we would this
was cause of this
hey when you land in istanbul maybe
we'll arrest you yeah like or whoever
would and then the turks would say you
got to take this you know you have to
take these down but it's illegal in
their country so if you go there you've
committed a crime here you have it yeah
but you have to so you have to you're
just being companies here you're just
being funny here you're just a pretty
good joke
but you have to abide by the countries
in which the platform operates or they
go to the office in that country and
arrest those people so you know you
can't just say like well
people anyway people have these simple
solutions for these things there are no
there are no like why don't you just use
the first amendment well because other
countries don't have the first amendment
they have their own speech role speech
laws i feel like i feel like what is so
frustrating to people about twitter is
the fact that even if twitter were to go
away or if you were to get everything
you wanted in terms of de-platforming
people
you would still find hatred and
immaturity and negativity and criticism
it would just be somewhere else and
you're just
well there would be there's an infinite
amount of things you you like there's
always another thing you wish that you
would be like well also if we're gonna
kick that person off why aren't we
kicking this person off and if we're
gonna prevent that why aren't we gonna i
mean there's always another there's
always another one there's always the
next one and what is it doing to us as
humans is it infantilizing us is it
giving us thin skin to go like i don't
want to see or hear this so it needs to
go away it's like what's gonna happen
when you go into work and have to work
next to someone that you don't like or
like it's to me it's just like trying to
create this environment where everyone's
treated with kid gloves and it's like
that's not how the world works and also
i look at twitter as just another
iteration of something that's already
existed which is like our addiction to
shot and freudia and um uh watching
people get publicly shamed which we did
it in roman coliseums we did in the town
square we've done it in many it's just
now it's twitter yeah people love to see
you know the people who are like climb
to the top of the mountain everyone
loves to see that person get knocked off
they love it yes and i think it's it's
very i think that twitter is a great
reminder of what we are capable of as
humans and a room just because it's
if you take down something the person
that said it and thought it still exists
like i think that there's a struggle of
like this isn't like a video game we're
like and then the person i'm like this
person is still it still exists there's
still people that hate me or don't think
women should do comedy or think i'm a
cunter like
i have to accept that those people are
out there whether there's proof of it or
not
they're out there there are people that
don't think women you said they're
people that don't think women should do
comedy
you you specifically i would like to
stop so can we please all just you
you would prefer it if you didn't
excuse to quit and so i needed to just
be canceled i don't know can we stage a
boycott or something i need a day off
um but uh
that is something because it does when i
i very much look at twitter as like like
pavlov's you know
dog experiment of just like being like
i'm gonna say more hateful and when you
respond and i think i always try to go
like what's the big human nature lesson
it's like you know on my uh off time i
rehabilitate animals and it's like when
there's bad behavior
the best thing you can do is just ignore
it that's the way to really make it go
away with an animal right is that if the
doctor is that why when the dog jumped
up on my lap you just left you left the
room you left the room
[Laughter]
that's that's that explains that we're
watching my 120 pound dog that's 150
maybe 120s
started moving up to you're like oh so
cute and then it jumped on you and
you're like jesus like what the fuck is
this by the way just for everyone it's a
great dane pit bull man yes it is giant
you are not a pussy that is it i was
shocked
i was shocked
and then yeah he's got it he's handled
he's ran twitter i think he's dealt with
something way more vicious than that
can i ask just um this is something i
just talked about my special because i
maybe this is my point of view because
the ship sailed for me in terms of like
the privacy stuff yeah i uh and i worked
with gary steingart to adapt the book
super statue love story which is all
fantastic by the way big fan
but yeah i'll give you the script great
i can't wait yeah so
he had done like a drama version to me
let's do the comedy version and it's a
dystopian satire about trying to fall in
love in the future let's say 2050 when
there's no privacy anymore like can you
truly fall in love with someone if the
minute you meet them you already know
their blood pressure you know everything
about their past have seen all their
naked photos have seen their texts from
10 years ago is it possible to fall in
love with someone if you actually know
who they are no
[Laughter]
because the whole conceit of love is you
you're able to hide yeah you idealize
this person and you can hide things and
hide things until they're stuck and
that's when you're like hey so can we
talk about my ford duis when i was in
cincinnati
um and so
you know the problem is people think
they want people say they want that but
then
the convenience of not having it is
amazing so for example you're coming in
i'm flying back into the states today
from mexico and you go through global
entry first of all the line to get
through immigration is like two hours
long but global entry it just looks at
your face now and goes please move
forward and then the guy goes you know
get costello and you walk forward and
you're like there's no way he pronounced
it right he didn't there's no way
that was a dramatization
but but the convenience of like it's
pretty good it just looked at my face
and i get to walk right through now
you're like yeah it's fine
and then you know
poof there's privacy is gone i mean your
face is in some database and they know
exactly who you are and pretty soon it's
minority report and you're walking
through the subway station and it's like
oh there's dick let's show them this ad
okay let's get let's couple things so
the whole that's one big concern people
have they're like they're gonna get my
data and they're gonna market ads to me
i am
i am gonna i
every time i see an ad it is something i
want and it makes my life easier
and i'm like those are this shoe that's
what that's one of them that was you
should get the other one i got that at
the day museum how dare you that's
rothy's their sponsor promo code whitney
um and i think they like every shoe you
buy like nine people in africa are fed
or something i don't know um so
i that doesn't bother me a ton because
maybe because i kind of grew up in
department stores my mom worked at you
know bloomingdale's neiman marcus i was
a perfume girl i would someone walk you
yeah
businesses have always been targeting
ads to us you would walk into a you know
department store and someone would go
she looked stupid and then they would go
you know what i mean she needs some
makeup come to the mac counter like
we've always been targeted by
advertisers i mean it used to be
bed bath and beyond used to put a coupon
every morning you'd wake up and never
i grew up in dc you'd wake up and there
were uh uh flyers for pizza places and
in your house they'd put it through the
thing and it was in your living room
they were more intrusive people will
come to your home
and shove things yeah and shut things
through the door yeah of course put them
in your mailbox whatever this isn't new
no it's not new you know so i think
that's not that it's good but it's
definitely not new you know i i mean
look i follow a lot of comedians i have
to watch a lot of comedians be like hey
i'm gonna be in tampa this weekend i
mean there's a lot of annoying
people marketing stuff i have to do it
too i have to target ads i mean i'm a
comedian i can't put coming to orlando
this week i ca no one's gonna you know
it's gonna throw off my algorithm i'm
gonna start getting q on fans whatever
so i have to target ads to just orlando
or whatever right just the trump rally
or whoever
so
i i think that's a little bit bratty
when we're like the ads are being
targeted to me no i'm saying people say
they want they want more privacy but
they um
in reality they opt for the convenience
when it's presented when the options
presented them they opt for convenience
i also think challenge me tell me i'm
wrong because i'm sure you have the
actual date on this um
i
know there's no such thing as gender now
cool but um also i do
comedians we generalize
i think there's a little bit of a
difference between
my guy friends are the most terrified of
the privacy stuff like i've of what do
you mean of um
being listened to being i have a really
friend of mine all right there's an
alexa in his house okay won't even
fucking talk around it
why is what's even happening being held
captive
by a machine
he bought like you go to his house like
what's up dude
it's right here
let's go downstairs and i'm like can't
you turn her off then she'll know we
turned her off that's the worst thing
then they know
that's when the other stuff turns on
and then it's like he's got tape on his
camera on his computer it's just
i
i think maybe
he's got like tape over the little
camera tape over the camera everything
but i guess for me as a woman i'm a
little bit like i want to be documented
at all times i want everyone to know
where i am what i'm doing because we get
murdered oh hello taking a break from me
trying to
keep my head above water while talking
to someone smarter than me
that doesn't happen often that's true
um
i want to talk about zocdoc
uh
i mean look no one needs more doctors
than emily and grace
oh god you're so right
it is a free app that shows you doctors
who are not only patient reviewed they
take your insurance and they're
available when you need them so
america
vark yeah if you need a doctor
i don't even know where you start you
don't you just
pray go to a neighbor's house and see if
they've got a tourniquet like i don't
even know what you do anymore if you
need to make a doctor's appointment
call 9-1-1 and hope somebody finds you
in time you just whatever your illness
is you just jump in front of a car yeah
and hopefully someone calls it you
collect the insurance payment or you
send a picture you find someone that has
a doctor you send a picture of whatever
you need checked out with your friend
and then they show their doctor and then
they'll try to give you an answer
enter
yes so this is an absolute miracle
and i've seen it i've seen it in action
i've witnessed this um you know
these kiddos when you guys need to go to
the doctor
you just make an appointment on your
phones yeah it's so easy and yeah
explain on zocdoc you can find every
specialist under the sun whether you're
trying to get to straighten those teeth
fix an achy back get that mole checked
out or anything else zocdoc has you
covered go to zocdoc.com whitney and
download the zocdoc app for free i have
it on my phone that's how i make all my
doctor's appointments then you start
your search for a top-rated doctor today
many are available within 24 hours this
is very um
just it is crucial innovative and
amazing and it's so easy to use you go
in and you don't
get there and then they go we don't take
your insurance
yeah yeah so easy that
z-o-c-d-o-c dot com slash whitney
zockdock.com whitney you will thank us
now back to the show
so i when i was when i was running
twitter i went to china to talk to some
people over there and see if we could
get china activated and and see if we
could get twitter activated in china
which is well which was a lol yeah
hilarious uh and lol to them too the
chinese the government officials were
like lol literally lol that's literally
like that was literally like
i would love to hear that everyone can
just say whatever they want whenever
they want yeah yeah they're like uh no
china's like uh absolutely also would
you like a bat roll yeah right so there
was this there was this professor over
there whose passwords were all
the chinese word for password because he
wanted the government to know that it
was easy for them to hack into his stuff
because he had nothing to hide so he
made his passwords easy for the
government to hack into
knowing that they wouldn't worry about
him if his passwords were super easy to
guess and i was like oh it's like it's
like we were just saying like that i
just want to be observed at all times
that's like a guy cheating man go
through my phone
do it no go ahead look take it and if
you do that you're like well now i can't
because you're like you're calling my
boss oh that was his move anyway hmm
don't know what happened now yeah don't
say don't know what it
he was a is
baby yeah
that is that is fascinating but um but
so what where where do you what are your
precautions you on a daily basis like is
your phone in airplane mode when you're
in a a hotel do you bring your laptop
into a hotel the only time the only time
i don't i don't stress about that stuff
the only time and you had to do it was
was when um was when i made this trip to
china the best part was they don't care
that you know that they're watching you
to be clear we're talking about the
chinese government yes not chinese
people correct we're talking about the
chinese government i will slam the
chinese government all day long so
people was was over there i opened my
hotel room door in the morning to go
down to breakfast meeting and there's a
like a half a cup literally a half a cup
of left of warm starbucks like on the
floor outside my hotel door like the
whoever was there like
making sure i didn't leave that night or
watching or whatever it was just like i
was gonna like finish half of this and
leave it here and i was talking to a new
york times reporter who is in china had
been working in chinese like yeah
they'll like
break into places and just like bring
their kids with them the kid will like
scribble on the desk and they'll just
like you know then at least they know
we're watching them now yeah they just
didn't care
that is a trip yeah
that is a trip um i have so many
questions and i don't want to um forget
them and you know my personality um so
first of all real quick can we i
normally start the podcast giving some
context on how we know each other just
so that it's uh
clear to everyone so nothing is awkward
but we sat next to each other for do you
remember how we met we sat next to each
other at a vanity fair dinner and then
we got to see each other a couple months
ago at a wild thing and i saw you and i
was like oh
he's here
yeah that was fun yeah it was just like
such a weird it was a like a big event
where at the last minute i realized i
had to cut like four pages of epstein
jokes because princess beatrice was in
the front row
[Laughter]
because also let me let me so a lot of
people you know say like surveillance
like people i don't want someone
watching me it's a lot of my guy friends
mostly i am generalizing because you
know and i'm with my guy from the most
like well don't do shady stuff like
don't go on 8-chan and don't like don't
get child porn like if you have nothing
to hide what but but it's also people
are entitled to have a private life and
private of course privacy you know so
so however it's like
privacy is all well and good until
someone shoots up at school and what if
we had just gone into his dms and seen
and maybe we could have prevented some
you know so for me i'm like
there's a little bit of we're so
obsessed with people's privacy that a
lot of people are doing like really
messed up things that look i'm not pro
surveillance until there's someone that
needs to be surveilled that could stop
other harm where do we like draw the
line how do you know
and like you know i am obviously uh
already on this podcast will criticize
china all day long for the way they
dehumanize people don't give them
privacy but at the same time i'm like
humans we've always had some kind of
surveillance like it does kind of make
us the best version of ourselves if we
know we're being watched a little bit
like i do believe that is why we
invented santa claus
like that is the only way to get kids to
not be complete dickheads they like
parents just had to be like someone's
watching you and they're making a list
of everything you're doing and they were
like okay shit
like humans left to their own devices
are usually going to do shady like is
there any benefit in a little bit of
surveillance
the problem is
and you know people always misunderstand
how this works with these companies like
twitter and facebook and google and
youtube and everything the problem is if
you if you give authorities unfettered
you know they can go look at anything
they want to look at and look at any of
the messages they want to look at in
order to like yeah prevent a crime
they'll eventually go look at stuff
they're not supposed to be looking at
for a personal trainer because that's
their human beings that's our human
nature so you have to have some you have
to have you know um
legal recourse to say uh that seems like
a weird request
yeah like you gotta give us you yeah you
have to have a warrant for that we're
not just gonna hand over the dms of
these accounts and is that you know
what's happening when we're on twitter
we're like hey we need yeah the the fbi
or other agencies or other international
groups would come to us and say hey we
need to see the direct messages for this
account and we would say all right like
show present uh you know legal because
terrace is dumb enough to put his plan
in dms i don't think he's going to pull
it off you would be surprised i think he
can fly you'd be surprised
i mean you know when you'd get these
legal requests that were valid legal
requests and there are tons of like not
valid legal requests like a government
thinking hey this person is a you know a
a protester in my country and i want to
find out where they live and go get them
and you know we wouldn't fulfill those
requests unless we had a valid legal
order from a court that we thought was
uh you know um
whatever fulfilling the legal
obligations of that country then you
know you have to you have to go turn
those over but lots of times would
requests would come in and i'm sure they
still do that we would not turn over
just because it seemed like
this seems like it's for political
purposes or this person's got a personal
vendetta against this account um
what do you think that happens all the
time just like you said it's people's
personal nature like
maybe i'll go find out you know what
this you know girl i want to date is
saying on in direct messages just you
just you know you have to have legal
you have to have someone or an
organization that's standing in between
the request and and the fulfilling
requests that's making sure it's a legal
request
and so this is boring but no i'm just
i'm just trying to not ruin your
eloquent answer with a stupid fucking
joke
you're such a wealth of information and
this is
this couldn't be a more crucial you know
time to have these conversations and i'm
trying to just not be an idiot about it
um because also like as you're saying
this it makes me think about
people take being censored on instagram
or twit so personally like they think
it's such a personal vendetta there's
this like you know i mean comedians that
make fun of them all the time like i've
been shadow banned like someone at
twitter
doesn't like me it's just like or
someone had instagram like they it's
like i don't think it i don't that's not
it doesn't work that way by the way
all that is that stuff is i'm people
will go crazy when i say this that stuff
is kind of nonsense there's like it's
not that stuff generally there aren't
people at these companies like dude you
have 20 000 followers no one thinks
you're changing the course of history
with your people people who come out are
like oh
it's
it's not that's not happening that's not
how those things work there are people
these companies you're exactly right
there are people these companies they're
going like this person in you know
wherever with 18 000 followers we have
to make sure that you know their stuff
isn't seen by as many people as it just
doesn't it doesn't work that way but
there are rules of course private which
is i remember there's this it's called
the tata top and it is a
it is a
key i don't know this rule it's a big
well it's a it's a it's a bikini that
is boobs and has nipples so you're
wearing it it has nipples if you look on
the bikini but they're like uh
airbrushed on i get it so it's like if
you look real quick it's just like kind
of fun you know it looks like you're
naked kind for a second hilarious
hilarious so funny that's why i get paid
the big bucks but uh but yes it's a
bikini top whatever so i posted in store
and the robot or whoever is calling
through right the robot yeah the robot
the algorithm but the algorithm is like
boobs but algorithms are different right
algorithm is the curated
um no there are multiple algorithms out
there there are multiple algorithms one
of the algorithms is used to go look
through pictures and go oh this is this
a robot this is a spider program it's a
it's a robot that that am i intimidating
you with my knowledge was pretty
impressive spider broke brighter program
pretty good okay pretty impressive
good use
um when you repost something instagram
or twitter or one of these platforms
there
was code that whips through it
especially if it's a photo or video and
like is this you know content okay or
not
or is it nudity or is it whatever do we
need to put something in front of it do
we need to prevent it from being posted
et cetera that's one of the algorithms
these are humans that's a robot that's a
robot that makes a first pass at like
hey can't post that it's nudity and i
think people are
you know it's interesting because people
are like robots are gonna take over next
it's like they're so dumb
right now and if they don't know the
difference between a naked woman and a
woman in a tata top which that is i
remember because when i did this robot
um built this robot for my last special
and had to talk to all these robotics
people forever and ever which is really
fun they're great at
conversations they're hilarious yeah i
love talking to other humans i have
decided the reason it is going to take
so long for robots to be able to have
any kind of human emotion or be able to
have emotion on their faces because
robots are being built
people don't who don't have that but the
the point that i'm making is oh i was
told uh by this amazing roboticist that
robots will never be able to
essentially be equate to humans or be
trustworthy until they can tell the
difference between a husky and a wolf
that was this person because that was
this person's
that's what it boiled down to because
the point was
they look the same to a robot
but a human can feel the difference
do you know what i mean i think that's
nonsense that's insane that's totally
that's like the
craziest
most incorrect thing i've ever heard
this guy didn't work there
i'll tell you when we're gonna know
when you see that husky over there i
know that's a husky
named biff
yeah no i don't think i mean like i
don't think that's good wolves and
huskies look it's like for the auto
drive no i get what you're saying it's
just no if i just explain it more i feel
like you'll agree with me
yeah i can see where this is going no no
no let me tell you what he was trying to
tell me no that's not when he told me
that i was like
that makes so much sense yeah that's
totally wrong see this isn't you know
who's too much power not robots people
that make robots he was probably like
you know what i just told when he comes
dude she's gonna like talk about that
and she's gonna look like such an idiot
she's gonna be like no then when they
can tell between huskies and voices
like whitney cummings is coming in we
need to use um dog metaphors to
communicate with her she's not gonna
understand anything else just talk in
huskies and retrievers
[Laughter]
but
just be in instagram whenever something
has happened i had like a nude leak
happen and so that the guy didn't sell
it i just put it on instagram i knew it
was going to mean you had a noodle
oh look who's not googled me no i don't
know what you mean by what i had a nude
leak happen i had a i was extorted by
new leak just sounds like i pissed
myself
in
bed my nude body does leak sometimes
it's a bummer um but i had like a photo
it was a screen grab of a video that i
had accidentally uploaded onto instagram
stories when i was high on edibles and
making uh
instagram and it was uh so i um
a bunch of people tried to like extort
me if you give me this much money i
won't give this to a tabloid or the
fappening or this was one of the one of
the uh without naming names i will say
one of the funny things that would
happen at twitter was i'm sure it still
happens this day is you'd get a call
from a celebrity's publicist or
crisis vr team say hey uh so-and-so's
account has been hacked you know um okay
like what's going on well someone posted
to the account from like you know
someone took over the account and posted
something and shouldn't have been posted
and you know gibson posted something
anti-submitting
you go and investigate like literally
every post ever has been sent from the
same device and like oh next day in the
paper like oh
so and so accidentally you know posted
but you know
it's all this stuff you're like oh yeah
yeah yeah i do think there should be a
breathalyzer whatever we would get so
it's going to be been actively like it's
24 hours before that person's in the
news for doing something they shouldn't
have done oh it's inevitable no i didn't
work on roseanne or anything i have no
idea what you're talking about i do uh
love the quote that
mike tyson said he goes the problem with
social media is that too many people
have been able to run their mouth and
talk shit without getting punched in the
face yeah i remember
a business person whose father is
particularly um
well followed on twitter who
name said you know the problem is my dad
has all these followers and he
he mistakes that for thinking he's
leading them somewhere
and it's fair it's a fair it's a fair
statement
it is amazing how the human brain can
make something feel so imp it is it is
why this god complex you get when you
get a little bit and it makes me go how
little affirmation and validation did
you get as a child that
these three people you know with their
profile pictures and egg it's still the
egg
and you're like i have to tweet to my
fans and you're like i mean people are
waiting for me to make to say something
about this that is
it i have to say something yeah
i have to chime in and i but what i'm
interested in is the impact it's had in
you know socialization in real life like
i find sometimes you're in a
conversation something like well that
show sucked and you're like
all right
you can you have five people that are
about to argue i think that's also part
of why everyone's so mad at each other
like i'm not talking to my brother
because he said this about this like we
don't we sort of atrophied our muscle to
be able to
say something defend it yeah and maybe
be wrong and then have a conversation
have a conversation about it instead you
can just lob in a grenade and then leave
the room and go get a for some reason it
sucks you're like jesus
don't silence me it's like well you made
a bad point but you could have just said
that you know
it's interesting and everyone you know i
i find that that people feel very
empowered to weigh in on things that
they know nothing about of course which
is kind of feels new i mean i re it's my
point of like the concert earlier like
hey i came to see this person yeah but
now the guy next to you is going to go
up on stage for three seconds and dj
who's that guy i didn't come to see him
when i was in college i remember being
like god i just don't know
all i said was i don't know i'm i don't
know shit like i didn't know anything
but now it's this thing
where everyone knows you know everyone
knows everything in it and has the right
opinion about it and once you put your
opinion in writing yeah you have to be
able to
go you know what i can give in new
information i can change my mind and
just because i put that on twitter
doesn't mean i can't change as a person
and grow like that's what worries me is
that you so much like crystallize the
person you want on social media and then
you can't outgrow too much of it yeah
too much of it is weaponized against the
person for anything they do in the
future it's silly well it's one because
someone's like three years ago you said
this i'm like yeah three years ago i was
completely different person
i didn't have prozac yet like well of
course
like of course i said 20 years ago you
did something dumb yeah no shit you
think that was bad
you did you see who i dated 20 years ago
did you see why he thought i should
marry 20 years ago yeah the the holding
people accountable to also the goal post
move on like what's of course it always
does throughout history the goal plus
move so something that was like well
that wasn't as crazy 20 years ago as it
seems now
but so the key is not to be mad at
what's inevitably happening and ride the
horse you know the direction it's going
which is like now we have to adapt and
we have to self-censor and we have to
act accordingly like are there certain
things you do in your life or don't do
based on kind of what you know like i'm
not gonna put that in writing i'm not
gonna send that photo i'm particularly
bad at that which of course guts has
gotten me into trouble um i probably
should be a lot better about that like
one of the things that happens is you
know you can reply to someone on twitter
and then the reply gets pulled out as
its own statement and you're like and
then people judge that you're like no i
was sarcastically responding to this
other person and yet it becomes its own
thing and then people judge you based on
well you said this well yeah that was a
reply to this other random thing this
person said and we were five you know
paragraphs into a conversation so all
that stuff is um annoying and you really
you really really really have to you
know you really would have to watch
every single thing you said i want to
backtrack on what i said about the
privacy stuff because i do believe when
it comes to like medical information yes
like this is you know i was reading
about how if your mouse like older
people if their mouth starts to be shaky
uh
their insurance provider will like get a
heads up that they might be
pre-alzheimer's i think that's i think
the wolf told me that in the hospital
the husky corroborated it he got the guy
the artificial intelligence robot friend
look alex jones is very smart if you
just give him a chance
okay
taking a break
it's that time
it's time to talk about why you haven't
gotten your shit together yet
why
i mean are there still people out there
that have not subscribed to ritual
the people without their shit together
that's true i mean it is if you like it
it's kind of it's interesting because i
look back at like all the things that i
procrastinated about and i'm like i wish
i had just flossed in my 20s i wouldn't
be going to dentist appointments all the
time i wouldn't have cavities in between
my teeth i wouldn't oh yeah you really
are an overachiever oh yeah no that's
the whole thing is that if you
can between your teeth which means they
have to scoop out both like it's an it's
a nightmare and i'm like i wish i had
just done that just take care of your
body and your brain same with it like
ritual delayed release capsule designed
to help reach the colon
not the stomach those are two different
things it's an ideal place for
probiotics to survive and grow and this
is their new probiotic in addition to
their amazing ritual vitamins which
you've been taking since before the
podcast dude if i had been taking
probiotics this whole time
my i used to be i mean i remember my
first job uh when i was a writer and
last called carson daly i would lie in
the bathroom
on the floor in fetal position like
during lunch breaks during breaks
because i just that's how bad my stomach
hurts yeah you know because i just
didn't know it's designed with moisture
controlled bottle technology to protect
probiotic strains so there's no need to
refrigerate and synbiotic plus and
ritual are here to celebrate not hide
your insides there's no shame in your
gut game that's why ritual is offering
our listeners 10 off during your first
three months visit ritual.com whitney to
start your ritual or add synbiotic plus
to your subscription today this is
essential don't be silly speaking of
something else it is essential yeah
therapy oh everyone should be required
to be in therapy
at least once a week well i used to not
agree
because
um it's i i think it's irresponsible to
tell people to go get therapy when it's
three hundred dollars that's so true
because it means you have to have a car
right you have to you have to totally
yeah be able to like pay the
better help has made it so that therapy
is actually accessible there's no excuse
anymore like it used to be that just
finding a therapist was like a
three-month project you had to take time
off work to like complete it with better
help now there's plenty of ways to
support a healthy brain better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat only therapy sessions
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to accept us
what about y'all have been you had a
therapy point recently any good uh
insights
like too many actually good yeah that's
great yeah good take good epiphanies
good epiphanies um good epiphanies
mostly about uh realizing that i have so
much work to do and i only just realized
i have so much work to do and i have to
be nicer to myself about the fact that i
have so much work to do well like on
yourself yeah
for sure oh a lot to unpack i thought
you were fully cooked and great no okay
unfortunately no but the thing is tell
her that i'm sorry therapy is a slow
burn you don't have anything
for me a lot of times just saying
something out loud to someone that has
no knows nothing about you third party
objective isn't gonna tell anyone else
just to be able to say
it without being accountable for it with
your friend group all the time right
yeah it's really helpful you can be
matched with a better health therapist
in under 48 hours and our listeners get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com whitney that's
betterhelp.comwhitney
back to the show here's the thing and
people who choose to not believe this
will not believe it but having run one
of these companies i can tell you most
of that stuff is nonsense it's just not
true it's just not true there's not like
it's watching your mouse to see how you
move the mouse and alerting like you
know the in the pharma companies about
you that's the way this is is this kind
of propagated by companies that are sort
of hucksters that need are trying to
sell a solution to and so they need that
to be a problem i.e probably or just
like there's another crazy conspiracy
theory and look i get it there's all
sorts of weird advertising coincidences
where you're like whoa wait a minute i
just said ugh and now you know if you
buy cigarettes like i mean i know there
are things some of that stuff is my
insurance gonna go up if i'm buying
cigarettes every day all right now
you're getting into weird now you're
getting a new error but here's what's
now i don't know i have a solution i i
got your solution for you because
everyone's like if i taco if i go like
alexa order me cigarettes or alexa like
stuff you just have to throw them all
you just every now and then like to to
balance it all out you have to be like
hey alexa
is it possible to eat too much kale
like i can't uh you just have to say
some shit you don't mean you have to
google stuff you don't mean every now
and then you have to be like uh how do i
donate to saint jude's hospital like you
just have to
google some shit just say you have no
intention of doing clean up your
algorithm how do i donate again to saint
john's hospital 20 years from now i'm in
a custody battle and they're looking
through my shit and i look like a hero
you just and pay for your drugs and cash
it's not that hard
to just get it you know what i mean get
ahead of it
computer
you know i mean in your uh ex's name
that's it to me i can't believe more
people don't like i'm like if you
thought that was true if you were like
okay this person's insurance isn't gone
and then go to every asshole's house you
know and just fuck with them
sometimes go like okay
if i'm in a custody battle in 20 years
are they going to look at my amazon
purchases
because they're going to be like that is
so much so you have random amazon
searches that have no intention of
buying just to make yourself look like a
better person i mean camille vasquez
from the representative johnny depp
could probably look at the amount of
bronzer i order and be like this bitch
went in blackface that is too much
bronzer so like there is i'm sure
if you know the idea of like if
everything i'm doing is i do i move
through my digital life as if everything
one day will be looked at i mean i just
i'm like that just makes me not have a
pit in my stomach yeah
here's the problem it's not the problem
it's just the reality
some things that happen
are hey you were being tracked like you
were in italy and you did a search on
google for this thing
yeah google knows you searched from
italy and you searched for this thing
italy and now you're going to see ads
for this
like whatever italian sweaters helpful
looking for one i'm chilly so but then
people extrapolate that do aha it's
following well no it's not like watching
your mouth we're not nothing's watching
you how shaky you are with your mouse
and sending that on to pharma companies
or anything that stuff just doesn't
happen most of that stuff is just not
that's just not true what you're doing
what you're looking for and where you're
looking for it from yeah that stuff is
tracked and then uh because my therapist
refuses to use insurance
uh maybe it's because my reports that's
a good sign
my reports are so upsetting that she'll
say she's like you don't want this you
don't want this in writing
i now realize how insulting this is i'm
now just putting together yeah it's not
probably not good no one else has had
this experience
she's like we should probably just not
go through her insurance like she's
protecting me
from future
drama with my privacy because she's like
you don't like if insurance companies
have this if i put this in writing and
you say
i want to kill myself or don't i don't i
love my life i want to be alive forever
um but uh
like i wonder like if it's if you can
the way that i mean just watching that
johnny depp amber her child just
watching them use these like recordings
against each other like all just sort of
like ring camera footage from the
elevator and you're just like oh my god
that's fair there's more of that there
is more of that choices
i cause i do believe humans should have
the freedom to make bad choices
you know what i'm saying humans are
always going to do shit like that and
do we all want to pretend that we don't
always do stuff that
i don't know how to put this you know
what the fuck i used to
we judge everybody else by their
behavior but we judge ourselves by our
intentions right we're like well i
didn't mean to do that
you're like yeah but you did it it's the
same thing you're judging that person
for yeah but i meant to do
it was to do blah blah blah anyway
intentionally all the time the ring
cameras don't catch intention
no they didn't you know they catch
impact so there's things like that where
you're just like okay this thing i put
in my house to uh you know be a security
camera is now the very thing that's
going to bury me in 10 years that may
just mean maybe it's the opposite we're
going this is the end of society i'm
like this might be the beginning people
actually might be good people now
because there's cameras everywhere
it's possible i don't think an ad for
the chinese government i don't know this
is going to be better for all of you
you're going to look you love cameras
everywhere
i'm usually the cynical person who's
always like you know but i'm this has to
be a step in it just has to be
like i just i don't know my big picture
like to go like okay
when trains
first you know were invented people were
terrified they were going to be
electrocuted and all this crazy shit how
did you get this stuff
the internet ever heard of it
that was what people were worried about
my trains were invented i'm going to be
i'm going to be electric
electrocuted
okay plus she's gonna look something up
just you wait because everything on the
internet is true
and factual i will go to if you don't
think i will not go to duckduckgo right
now i will
okay
i am right now on a little search engine
called google and if it's wrong that
seems like it's your fault
in what capacity did you work with
google
fear
of electrocution on early trains the
railway seemed to cause anxiety and
concern about madness because of the
noise and unpredictable nature of the
railways there were also beliefs within
the medical profession that the
vibrations of the railway carriage could
have disastrous effects on people's
nerves why did people fear trains the
phobia of train tracks generally hinges
on two main concerns so fear of acts
that's a different thing that's phobia
but when a new wow yes you like have
researched that oh i am amazing how
everything we're dealing with now has
always existed it just looked different
yeah yeah fair you know maybe that's my
tarot management theory and how i'm able
to sleep at night or maybe it's the
prozac i should go down take a less
less uh milligrams but it is i get
fascinated by we always think the new
thing
yeah the new ostensible progress is
different and crazy and bad but it's
really more just a reflection we're
looking in the mirror right so and then
when elevators were invented people were
worried it was gonna give them cancer
and they were gonna catch on fire and
stuff like that you know so
i this is true
should we just name rename this podcast
i swear this is true even though you're
so much smarter than me i swear this is
true
when you were like running
like search browsers i was using them so
i we could argue that i know more
you were typing in future good deeds and
search browsers whitney cummings nudes
trying to get my
pornhub search up i was on pornhub
trying to trend
my photo i was trending on pornhub but
um so the point is all these things have
been with us for a while i just feel
like maybe i'm just being like you know
naive and hard-headed but i just think
that it's not about the technologies
about what we choose to do with it and
it's us it's us the common denominator
and all these things that we're mad at
is us of course and these are just
um things that accentuate what's in
it's like having a couple drinks it's
like twitter you find out who you are
it's like the real you comes out when
you've been on twitter for 20 whatever
it is and i think that it's like
wherever you go there you are and we
keep trying to go from platform to
platform trying to find
a safe place it's like you know it's
we're going to go to clubhouse and then
we're going to go no i do agree with
that and then it's toxic it's like it's
hard to hold these companies accountable
to human behavior and human nature i
mean there are things that the companies
do that you know you can oh they should
have done this or they should have done
that but it's hard to hold these
companies all of them accountable to
just human nature you know people are
gonna if people can snipe at each other
without any negative consequences and
just coming in like you know dunk on you
and leave and run away they're gonna do
it and that's what they did on the
playground they did it in high school
they did it in college
you know and so to me it's like animal
behavior it's like okay if the inherent
nature of like wild horses are violent
right when they're what and
wild horses are violent they fight they
all right i believe
you don't have to look it up right now
what's it like to talk to someone who's
so much smarter than you is it weird it
must be weird
weird
um no but
you can say okay there's these ten wild
horses they keep fighting well we need
to put better we need to put a better
fence up yeah and then they break down
the fence and you're like well why
didn't you just build a stronger fence
and you're like okay and you're never
gonna get them as soon as that fence
breaks it's gonna happen so that to me
is what what what all these
it's not just twitter it's all these all
of them yeah they're trying to get them
too before you just make this rule
everyone's gonna play nice of course not
gonna happen that's the problem with did
people think that's that's what i'm
trying to get at it doesn't mean that
these companies shouldn't do anything it
doesn't mean i'm not saying
it abdicates responsibility for them
obviously they should try to do the
right thing and and point things in the
right direction you just it's just the
case that there's no simple everyone
everyone's gotta well if twitter or if
instagram or if they just did this
everything would be fine it's never it's
never that there are 19 exceptions to
every one of those simple rules you come
up with yes so it's just not it's just
not that easy doesn't mean these
companies shouldn't do anything and they
do and they work hard at it it's just
not as easy as as everyone thinks it is
yeah it just it feels to me like just
okay then we're gonna it's whack-a-mole
you know i'll give you an example like
when isis posted these videos of like
let you know lighting that journalist on
fire in the cage and burning him alive
and they posted these videos to twitter
we're like all right we gotta take down
all the isis videos of the journalists
being burned alive that's crazy well the
new york post
their their tweet is the cover of the
next day's new york post is the guy in
the cage being burned alive and general
counsel comes and goes okay well now
what we told everyone to delete all the
suspend all the accounts that post the
isis the ice is burning the journalists
alive but now the new york post just
tweeted the photo of him but they're
trashy tabloids no i was like okay well
shoot that's like a now they're doing it
for news purposes like we're not going
to suspend the new york post and you
know this might just like came to me and
i was like all right well we can't
suspend the new york times they post i'm
sorry so it ends up being posted anyway
it ends up being like okay well we had
this thing that we saw like couldn't
have had a simpler rule no photos of the
guy being burned alive suspend all the
accounts seems like an obvious decision
yeah and then it turns out like two
hours later you're like yeah not so
obvious anymore here's one that's a u.s
newspaper that's posting it and i guess
we should leave it up and now you're
like okay now we're gonna do we gotta go
decide about everyone else who posts it
whether we should leave it up or not are
they an isis account or are they just
like some
uh you know news newspaper around the
world posting it it's just nothing's
ever as easy as we'll just do that and
apply that to everything it just doesn't
work that way and then so as a life
lesson uh gleaning wisdom we should
always take life lessons away from all
these things
okay wild horse what have we learned so
far hey wild horses are violent they're
very bad we will know there's true
artificial intelligence where they can
distinguish between a wolf and a what a
husky
all right can i i here's let's continue
you know that could be i define
comedians as people who say things that
aren't true and then prove it so i will
wear you down on this so a wolf in a
husky the point is humans have a gut
instinct yeah that that that robots
don't have right robots are just working
on a point system right i'm not okay
your brain is also working on a point
system that's giving you the gutter the
gut instinct is appropriate two
milligrams of prozac
but if if you're dry if you're doing i
don't do auto drive do you do auto drive
in the tesla i know i don't i don't
trust that i love you lex freeman love
you very much but i'm not i'm not using
it yet because i don't think that i'm
not i can anthropomorphize a um
uh uh like any robot which it's weird
like uh a roomba yeah i feel like when a
roomba gets stuck under the couch i'm
like buddy like i
that is i feel bad for it my fear is not
the robots are gonna hurt us it's that
we are gonna get emotionally invested in
them and kill each other because we're
protecting them as if they're like of
course that's totally going to happen
it's like a pet because we've
anthropomorphized them which is right oh
interesting question do you think that
robots should have human faces
i mean they're going to it doesn't
matter whether they think they should or
not they're totally going to have human
basis
i mean of course they are
what do you like
i know i'm just because you know
everything in my brain it's still up for
debate you're like i mean it can be it
doesn't matter if it's up for debate
they're going to you immediately
it's like when people say well we have
to have ethical ai to make sure the
robots don't do this i'm like well north
korea is not going to do that so then
they're just going to have robots that
are smarter than ours and kill ours so
we all kind of just have to do what the
worst person is doing
is that kind of
how business works
you just have to do what the cartoon
villain is doing so that you don't die
is that kind of
because i'm also thinking because that's
not precisely the takeaway i was getting
at but you know i think it ends up being
the conclusion that some people come to
cause also
you know who can't tell the difference
between huskies and wolves is
north koreans when they're eating them
so
the point
but um but robot because the idea of are
we more or less likely to
anthropomorphize a robot if they have a
human face or not of course you know of
course robots will probably just figure
it out and if they don't have a human
face like i should probably mr potato
had this shit and like i'm coming yeah
yeah they're gonna put one on i know how
to make sure i don't get thrown out i'm
gonna make sure i don't get turned off
i'm gonna make this bitch fall in love
with me
um but uh the robots
we
uh where was i going with that do you if
i was a robot i would remember neuralink
are you gonna do it
which i mean like what are you
specifically getting if we get a little
chip in our lifetime where i we can read
each other's thoughts no that sounds
horrible i agree yeah i agree
no and like a lot of do you want us to
read your thoughts no i don't think you
want this product i don't want that for
myself or anyone that's that's where i'm
really like no humans are designed to
think horrible things and then go you're
not allowed to think that you're not
allowed to think that
do this
you know what i'm saying that's what
humans are just a compilation of a bunch
of horrible thoughts and then you go
you're not allowed to do any of those
you know what i'm saying yeah
i'm saying guys
neuro-linguistic butt spots butt spots
like you can't your first couple of
reactions to something is your
programming your imprinting
your fear reactions agreed just really
quick since you by the way also dick did
improv and a little stand up right yeah
and so i think of you kind of like as a
comedian in a weird way and then i meet
you and then always like runs twitter
jesus and um but uh i would love to know
how improv like sort of prepared you for
all these like incredibly high-powered
jobs because i think everyone should at
least once or twice like just try to do
stand up try to do 100 i totally agree
just as an exercise in fear and yeah one
of the great things about it as you i'm
sure you know is
this
that's so weird is like god this was
worked so well last night and now it's
like crickets it's weird it also teaches
you oh
this i'm not like necessarily the
you know
everything i do doesn't turn into gold
like you learn like oh this thing that
worked in one environment and i'm doing
the exact same way
to kind of the same size crowd in the
same kind of theater is now like zero
it's a weird experience it's a weird
thing to experience that and go what
happened you can't go on autopilot it's
like it's like it's like it's like
anything it's like
when you're you know
dating someone that you know a new
person and you like hook up and you're
like oh now i know exactly what makes
your ex have an orgasm like
what was that okay that i know
everything i need to know about your ex
but you can't just go into the same
thing that you did
you have to unfortunately be present and
every new whether employee or person you
have to go okay i'm starting from
scratch i can't just go into my stick i
also think doing stand-up and improv is
a great way to learn
that no one's getting away with anything
yeah and to pay attention you just said
it earlier you have to pay attention
it's such a it was a lesson i needed to
really
you know i think everyone should learn
and um i also think that there are so
many jobs now that require some
iteration of public speaking yeah and
people we gotta quit with this shit
because there's too many super qualified
people for politics and stuff who
because they're bad at public speaking
or they don't have that sociopathic
charm
are never gonna do it it's a nightmare
you know so it's like we gotta get
aspiring politicians in to uh ucb that's
my platform this is my platform we need
to get marian williamson to do that
we need to get a buddha judge into
rooster t feathers up in sacramento um
so in terms of people knowing thoughts
you don't want to have you don't want to
see anyone else's what anyone else is
thinking like in real time it's just
stupid and
it is stupid it's a horrible idea like
it's miserable i don't want to see what
i'm like i don't want to see a readout
of what i'm thinking in real time
why did i think about that while we were
having this discussion that was weird
that the only pro like i don't like
technology that solves problems that no
one has yeah the only person's problem
that's solving is a girlfriend who's
like what are you thinking about
do we really want to cater to her
is that the person we're building
technology for no when you're making a
big decision um
you know just hearing you talk and just
the amount of pressure and stress yeah
ultimately when like the rubber hits the
road and the decision has to be made
what percentage is your gut instinct
what percentage is based on some data
you heard or read and when i'm just
making the rational decision based on
this data and what percentages asking
people that you trust or yeah and then
making a that's a great question i got i
was i'm i'm probably maybe over indexed
for gut instinct so when i first started
out as ceo i would make decisions
rapidly and on gut instinct and i got
better at
uh maybe get some feedback from some
people who you know
aren't the ceo of the company and have a
different perspective on like how this
is going to affect everybody and blah so
i got better at let me check let me just
go check out my before i go tell
everyone what i think let's get let's
gather some feedback i got better at
that over time i'm probably over indexed
toward gut instinct and
how
as like a leader and what's changing in
uh
you know this
you know listening to y'all i mean i
think we're kind of in a place where
you're going like okay
you know my 25 year old assistant
probably knows more about some shit than
i do yeah and i know a lot more about
shit some shit than she does of course
you know yeah and
i do believe that this you know
everything this younger generation the
inmates are running this they know a lot
of shit we don't know we know a lot of
shit but i believe like any animal
species which we are the younger is
always testing the older of course and
sometimes it's our job to go no bitch
shut up you're wrong you know what
you're talking about you know yeah
that's exactly right and they'll scream
and cry and now they can tweet so that's
you know a little bit more of a you know
a backlash than just someone being mad
at you or grumpy but you know i think
that like a lot of times you know animal
training is you know sort of more my
empirical experience but a lot of times
you have to go
you have to be ostensibly sort of bitchy
in order to save the animal's life down
the line so i'm going to use this
electric shock collar twice so that you
don't run into traffic next week yeah
yeah yeah i mean so yeah how i always
used to tell people inside the company
you know like
assume that your co-workers have the
best intentions of the company in mind
when they're doing something you may not
know you know you're in engineering you
know i may not know these people in
sales so you're like why do those people
do blah blah they just want to make more
like assume that your co-workers are
trying to do the best thing for the
company like you are
and maybe the thing doesn't work out or
does work out but assume they're trying
to do assume the best intentions don't
ask questions that assume your colleague
or me or another member of the team is
like
trying to screw you or trying to be a
bad person you mean this person doesn't
spend their entire day trying to
sabotage you no you can like ask a tough
question but it has to come from an
assumption of we're all trying to do the
best thing for the company it is that
i'm a piece of shit in the center of the
universe it's like everyone is trying to
fuck me over it's like no everyone's
just trying to do their job and i think
i think that maybe because we've been
online so much we sometimes are like
we're a little bit uh atrophied in terms
of when people are direct it's like i
mean i'm seeing people losing their jobs
and you know the t a lot of people you
know shouldn't be around other people
and have power in my business great but
there's a lot of people that just their
demeanor is very direct and clear yeah
and people like well he's being mean to
me and you're like whoa if directness is
not yes i totally totally agree with you
there like you if sometimes that
sometimes it became
sometimes tough questions in other
companies or in other with other leaders
became you know what we're just not
going to tolerate that anymore this is
what we're doing if you don't like it
leave like
hey you wanna you want people to ask
tough questions because if things are
messed up and you know you've got a
distorted perspective as the leader you
want to find out about that as quickly
as possible that like hey everyone
thinks this is crazy and messed up and
you know you want to know about that so
i always wanted to hear that i just
wanted people to like hey assume that
we're all trying to do the right thing
go ahead and ask tough questions but
don't ask it from an assumption of i'm
trying to be a jerk or i'm trying to
screw you being defensive or something
yeah that is a that is a such a great
piece of advice because i do think a lot
of us operate as if we're like at war
all the time because we kind of are in a
lot of ways but i think that like the
default of like
uh
moving through life the default is
everyone is on your side until proven
otherwise have you ever had to like
like there's a little bit of this like
workplace like cash vibe that i'm
i'm open to all these like new like ways
working from home maybe you can get more
done because you're not commuting and
you're not whatever i'm sure there's
like way more optimal ways to
i'm not a big working from home person i
don't i don't think it's like ideal
you have to be like you have to
see people that you're working with and
you'll there's stuff that's exchanged
and just casual conversation in the
hallway
around desks and stuff that you learn
that you just don't get drinking a glass
of chardonnay in your pajamas sitting in
the break room and uh yeah who you
running in the bathroom yeah whatever or
just like
conversing at your desk or someone pops
by and asks a question like that you're
not available for if you're just sitting
at home on your laptop yeah and it's
yeah those zoom meetings i know they
serve their purpose at a time when we
needed them but i cannot look at someone
in front of a fucking fake palm tree
anymore like i can't do anything it's
psychotic yeah it's psychotic like i
don't
i'm not gonna trust you with this
project
[Laughter]
if you can't figure out a ring light
like why does this look like the blair
rich project like you've had two years
to figure it out like you've got two
years to figure out your lighting and
yet here we are in this room filled with
i mean sweatshirt over there that hasn't
been worn in a while okay well that's my
merch that's my merch so 60 bucks and it
can be yours um okay i'm not gonna keep
you too much longer but i um i always
ask on podcasts uh red flags and um the
wisdom of someone like you red flags and
people we spend a lot of time i mean you
seem like you're so clear and you have
such an incredible gut but like i think
a lot of us you know sometimes hire the
wrong people yeah work at the wrong job
because we
date the wrong people marry the wrong
because we just miss little red flags
and
i
mine are everywhere from where's heels
to the airport to
has a man bun
to
you know what man bun is bad i just bat
that's a bad one i'm just curious about
your i mean
on a first date is on is on their phone
if you've been dating someone for three
months and they have to do uh put their
phone face down only
if you go to look at their phone and
like
like those are big ones those are big
ones just curtis and your career is
hiring people
uh
you know
bring trusting i used to ask people
during interviews uh just to see like i
would always try to get a sense of like
this person like have any like are they
like self-aware they've realized like oh
we're all just people and you know i got
to do stupid things just like everyone
else does so it always asks people and i
got this from this person who ran hr for
me for a while um i would always ask
people
hey if in the middle of an interview i'd
just say like hey if we're at a bar like
with a bunch of your friends what are
they giving you shit about
you know just to see what the person
would say you know just to see if they
had any sense of like oh i do this
stupid thing and
you know blah blah blah blah and they're
probably giving me a hard time about
that and then i would have asked then i
would later on ask okay if i'm not a if
you've now left and i'm at a bar at the
bar with your same friends now what are
they saying
you know and just get just to get a
sense of like
maybe like even if the person said like
jeez i don't know shit i've never even
thought about like what they say when
i'm not there probably horrible things
that's great that's an authentic that's
great that's an authentic response but
like you know sometimes people will say
like i don't know i'm just honest man
you know i'm honest and some people
can't deal with that and if you can't
deal with that you know that's your
fault and i'm like oh oh
that's bad yeah so those are just i
would kind of always do that stuff you
need to call your dad yeah maybe you
should get a puppy yeah
just to see if people have any sense of
self-awareness it's people who don't
have that any of that that i'm like what
would you say to that i would always say
like i don't know i talk too much i
intend to like
people are asking me a question i'll
like start answering it in the middle of
their question instead of like letting
them finish because i'm like no no i
know what you're going to ask
[Laughter]
it's not an interruption if you're just
saving time it's not i yeah he knows
where it it's just thank you i'm
impatient i'll start if people are
asking me a question i'll start going
uh-huh you do it
i get so much i'm ready to answer the
question already we're doing it to each
other right now this is my dream
he's cut me off most everything and i i
was done i'm just lingering you know
you're giving the other person time to
have a water like you're just like i
appreciate that so much
cause it's like i know what your
question is you're wasting everyone's
time i don't have time
i love that you do that that is not rude
you're actually everyone's getting home
like an hour earlier if you just
interrupt people and like if you're
bored
would you rather me interrupt you or
look bored
you can choose um and then what would
you say about people what do they say
about you when you leave
i have no idea i'm sure it's something
horrible i have all sorts of like little
stupid like idiosyncrasies so it's
probably something about that you know
like i don't i don't know i have like
lots of physical like my my pinky
fingers all point the wrong way like
they're weird and they look kind of
deformed i don't know i have lots of
little weird physicals so when you leave
you think your friends are like i don't
know like they're probably like
check out the myths on that freak
i don't know i just i don't know like i
would expect someone that ran
internet companies to have weird fucking
fingers i'm like they just you know do
the thing like that you do if you're
like in you with a history at all in
comedy if you say something funny you're
like i should say that again it'll be
funny it'll be
there are a couple people who didn't
hear it
i do that i'd do that too much that's
just that's just being of service to the
people that didn't hear it surface you
know what i mean we call that just being
helpful yeah why would stuff like that
it's called spreading joy you have lots
of little just weird personality like
you oh but the other people have to hear
it twice
yeah the other people have to hear it
twice you know a little personality
this is actually what i don't like when
people do uh when they're they've told a
funny story or said a funny joke and
they're gonna say it again with new
people there and other people already
heard it and they have to qualify i mean
we talked about this earlier but it's
like yeah i'm not yeah taking care of
you
this is what humans do we we get a trick
and then we do our tricks for other
people this is stop pretending yeah that
if you had a killer story and more
people showed up you do you have a
better story then then i'll shut up do
you have anything to say
yeah i don't think you have to apologize
for being entertaining all right fair
good
i mean
interesting interesting interesting i do
have to ask you about silicon valley
just okay did you have such a blast oh
my god it was the best it was great i'll
tell you the funny thing the fun thing
about working on silicon valley was
first of all the writer's room there was
insane insane
mike judge i mean like i'm not gonna
yeah all of the whole the whole thing
but alec berg who was show runner for it
also just barry ellison i don't know
he was so polite
and nice to me whenever i whenever i
would like work up the courage to
actually pick pitch something
like would go yeah yeah or or
alternatively we could do this because
it was great he never said like that's
the stupidest
we're not definitely not that never
works you would just go yeah yeah yeah
or or alternatively i was like oh all
right but that's it i love that put it
in that put a pin
we'll maybe come back to that or or but
meanwhile let's go do these other things
sure sure that's cool but we have to
make a tv show so we'll come back to
that um
no i think the greatest and here's what
i will say they were great i loved
everyone in their room really awesome on
this like mr rogers kick but i think
that most people in television are good
people we only hear about the bad people
and it sort of weighs our sort of um
data in a way we think everyone's like
the two two of the best shows
you know on tv in the last six seven
years that were run by and a wonderful
man who's brilliant and kind yes he's
hilarious no one writes stories like
particularly
he's a super nice guy yeah like that's
not a deadline headline you know so it's
like i also think the i also think that
being kind yields the best work i mean i
don't think it's a coincidence that he
was kind and also he's making the best
shows yeah yeah no that was that was i
loved it i loved it it was it was such a
like talented room
it was great i loved being in there oh
god i love that show so much um okay
what a dream
what are you doing anything for the
summer like do you just
how are you doing everyone's in italy
why aren't you in italy i don't know
you gonna travel anywhere
we'll see can you go to turkey where
would we land on that i think i can go
now really yeah i think i can go now i
end these very awkwardly is there
anything else like working on twitter no
anything
what a dream i hope you'll come back i
feel like i i hope i
i think people are going to be mad let's
see what happens and we'll call we'll do
it again yeah i love you what a dream
thank you so much um uh don't ride
elephants
one point
[Music]